if you had one free throw and you had  and you made it you get a million  dollars but if you miss you never get to  text again would you shoot it [ __ ] that  i wouldn't even take that chance because  i need to text no what what what i could  i'm getting much money for you take the  shot if it was 10 million you should do  it  okay but how far the free throw line  right it's like that thing  no no that's the three-point line free  throw line is like the like the straight  line across when you get fouled then you  just get to shoot it by yourself  so it's a little bit closer so three  pointers pretty far away yeah it's like  the one where you get like multiple  chances to do it okay no i wouldn't do  it anything  no 50.  maybe for like 100 yeah i mean for 100  million  how much money is in your bank account